je voudrais évoquer un sujet sur la
circulation c'est le aujourd'hui le
problème d'encombrement sur la lino et
sur la rocade
en fait ce problème il est doublement
pénalisant il est pénalisant pour le
doute pour l'activité le dynamisme de la
métropole parce que les déplacements se
font difficilement l'accès aux zones
d'activités économiques se fait
difficilement il est pénalisant
également pour l'environnement puisque
on a effectivement une augmentation des
rejets de gaz à effet de serre liées aux
déplacements
donc nous souhaitons nous investir très
rapidement sur la réorganisation des
ronds-points de valmy dailly et de la
jonction avec l'arc fonctionne pas bien
une manière de manière de manière à
décongestionner les embouteillages sur
le niveau baisser les impôts investir
est à refaire l'église saint-philibert
transformer le parc d'exposition est
donc en deux ans la vie la faillite avec
vous ça ça oui vous savez monsieur
monsieur le maire sortant la capacité
d'investissement de la commune est de
plus 30 millions d'euros par an la
capacité d'investissement des métropoles
de 60 millions d'euros par an donc et
les ronds-points jeu ça peu près combien
ça coûte parce que j'étais vice
président du conseil général quand on a
fait les l'échangeur du zénith